de santé, il peut déjà
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait
ailleursa fait la fait la fait c
le système de santé ontarien.
- Elle s'appelle
Marylie Crépeau. Elle a 27 ans
et elle
à Lauralie il y a sept mois.
Et voici Jessica Benedicto,
37 ans, fière maman de Lorenzo,
quatre mois.
expériences fort différentes :le
Montréal; l'autre, à Toronto.
Nous soWellesley-St-James.
Une infirmière enregistre
le poids et la taille
du petit Lorenzo.
les poupons de son âge.
sur place, et en moins de
cinq mincinq mincinq mincinq mie
qui illustre bien la qualité
des soins que reçoit Jessica.
Pourtant, sa grossesse(&
n'a pas . Son bébé
se développait trop lentement,
et elle a dû recevoirer.
Mais ja
sentie négligée.
- Tout ce qui vous reste
à faire, c'est d'aller peser
- En clinique, à Terrebonne,Mare
le poids de son enfant.
- Au Québec, il faut être
débrouillard dès
suivi de grossesse.
MARYLIE CRÉPEAU
de listes de médecins à appeler,
ai appelé plusieurs
fois, puis après quatre, cinq
appels, à force dister,
ils m'ont donné un médecin
de famille, puis là, j'ai pu
rentrer dans le système.
qui fait ces démarches
auprès d'un gynécologue.
Les rappels de vaccins aussi
sont plus compliqués au Québec.
chose d'assez compliqué,
d'appele d'avoir
des rendez-vous. Ça a été
comme... J'ai été en listevait
de la place, ils m'ont prise.
cela.
- J'ai appelé mon médecin de
de place avec deux, trois mois.
it plus cait plus cait plus caie
nourrir. Alors, j'étais vraiment
en panique. J'ai du aller
s'attendre à voir son médecin,
un médecin de garde ou une
infirmière praticienne,
Au Québec, Marylie doit prendre
un rendee
sans rendez-vous.
ordinateurs en même temps,
pour mon
enfant. Encore une fois
je me ramasse à l'urgence.rtants
dernières données, on trou
plus d'omnipraticiens
par 100 000 habitants au Québec
contre 115. Même chose pour les
médecins
128 contre 114.
Le Québec dépense aussi plus
d'argent par habitant en santé.
L'an dernier, c'ét$
Ce n'est donc pas un problème
de ressources, mais
d'organisation, selon ce
spécialiste des politiques
PIERRE-GERLIER FOREST,
Universiaryaryaryaryaryaryaryary
- On lance des réformes pendant
des périodes d'expansion,
de contraction des financespublp
de nos réformes en plan.
On n'obtchangements,
les transformations, le malaise,
puis on obtient à la fin les
fruits qui étaient attendus.- Ts
nous parlent encor
en disant : "Ah, vous avez ça
au Québec. C'est fantastique."
on en parle toujours.
me inspiré
l'Ontario dans sa propre
réforme, rappelle la Dreité
de Toronto. Mais le succèsontare
ingrédient.
Dre DANIté de Toronto
- On dit aux médecins :
Vous êtes en charge de cette
population de 1000 personnes.pa,
par mois.
- Un changement du mode
de rémunération.
- Cette approche-là, qui est
vraiment centrée sur le patient.
des omnipraticiens comme
à se consacrer
presque exclusivement
au travail en clin
médecin de famille- Je pouvais e
soin de mes patients,
ence en même temps.
- Les médecins québécois sontces
de temps en cabinet au Canada.
Résultat
- C'est sur que j'aurais plus
de place au bureau si je faisais
pas de salles d'accouchement,
ça qui permettrait à mes
patients d'avoir d
soins? Je pense pas.se spécialis
obstétriques. A so
forcer les médecins à rester
en clinique serait
Dre GABRIELLE CÔTÉ-GAGNON,
médecin de famille
- Pour moi, la médecinede suivr,
de l'accoucher et
son bébé.
- Elle croit que la solution
partage des responsabilités,
infirmières.
- De me priver de l'activité
le plus, je pense pas que
ervice
à personne, là.
- Comme Jessica, Marylie
apprécie beaucoup son médecindet
jamais dans le service, mais
dans l'e
Parce que de Lorenzo à Lau
de l'Ontario au Québec,
les beso
♪ ♪